hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to house another horror game
that proves doesn't prove anything
because i haven't played it yet i don't
know what i'm talking about
i'm going to play the game now
from what i know about this game it is a
pixelated horror game
that uh is deadly i think anyway
oh all right cool
well look at me go moving day
ever since the move i sometimes can't
tell if i'm awake or if i'm dreaming
the days are starting to blur together
all right
so there is hi doll how are you doing
i guess i'll oh old shift to sprint
well i don't know if that's the best
idea
i flush the toilet
ah i have a limited duration
[Music]
there's something in there i can hear it
whispering to me it wants me to do
horrible things maybe it will stop if i
listen
yeah why not why not i'll listen to the
turlet
i ain't a turtle ignorer
[Music]
i'm not hearing anything
i'm not hearing anything hmm
seems like a whole lot of nothing to me
[Music]
oh
okay so was that me sleeping or was that
me dreaming did i dream that a toilet
monster
emerged and ate my face i see
i see i oh
hi hey what's up
how you doing let me just blap hey wake
up
wake up wake up wake up wake up
hello hello
wake up wake up okay this is a little
strange
i'm just gonna yeah i'll i'll leave
okay that's kind of weird um
whoo what is this
why are you nailing my
mom what do you say about sleeping in a
friend's house tonight
what do i say about that what what do i
say about what do you say about that mom
[Music]
mom
this is moderately unsettling i'm
partially perturbed about all of this
hey uh how's it uh
how's it going in there you good you
good okay i'm gonna just go
hey mom cat kitty
hey how you doing yeah okay well that's
good do you change your mind if the
lights are off
yeah my sprint ain't too quick meow
whoa hi we're fine
hello i hate what he did
[Music]
uh hey
okay what's going on up here
hey what's up i'm trying to play leave
me alone tabby
okay well i know my name now very very
good
i appreci you're playing um
[Music]
i should run this is one of those
movements in horror movies where people
don't run
and instead i turn the lights out
oh hello young lady i was just peeping a
little yeah
yeah i smelled blood and thought
something may be wrong
there's always something interesting
going on here and you seem to be in a
predicament
there must be a way to stop these freak
accidents be sure to check every room
wouldn't want to miss anything sometimes
the answer you need is not in plain
sight
run along now dear there's much to be
done
[Laughter]
ah mommy wants milk
oh
[Music]
don't die over spilled milk
this game is this game is delightful i
love this
[Laughter]
i don't have anything to say about that
okay so maybe there was something about
my room you know
in the darkness and the darkness
maybe i could go back to slip in the
darkness
is this one of those games where all my
only objective is to die
in every way possible i don't know what
kind of life lesson that's teaching me
but uh
all right maybe i'll just watch tv for a
bit
i mean that seems kind of disastrous
whatever that's happening seems like
some kind of fire going on
maybe the statue of liberty or maybe
like a green zombie monster or something
like that in the middle of the woods
[Music]
nope seems like nothing okay anyway
um hey petunia oh hi
what's your name i hate what he did and
what
i hate everything i hate mornings i hate
what he did
i hate myself i hate this room i
hate these walls i hate everything i
hate this house
i hate mornings i hate what he did
i hate my life this is horribly
depressing
ah that's much better
all right later see
hey where did the painting and dad go
anywho just gonna get out of here
oh it's locked huh front door
no go
okay yeah what happens if i talk to this
oh
oh what do i do with this what do i do
with this nonsense
well that didn't sound good
oh
this bear trap gonna fall on my head oh
oh my face why did that happen
oh okay well um
well that's horrifying my goodness hello
dying at first it hurt but i'm starting
to not feel it
i can't even tell what's real anymore
i've woken up on the same day three
times now
yeah i don't think you're waking up dude
i don't think you're waking up i'm just
gonna say it straight up
i don't think you're awake what happens
if i run straight here
nah it's still not working
kitty is asleep kitty is very asleep
okay so there's like water there i
wonder if i can fix tab to cycle
[Music]
no no no mom wait
mom no
[Music]
well now there's milk what good did that
do
what good did that do me it says tab to
cycle but i don't know why
tab cycle oh between pick up and open i
get it okay i see
hi mom i got a bowling ball careful with
that that's your father's lucky ball
all right ooh milk for the cat
right but i already uh i already dumped
it all
okay
well i certainly do not want to kill my
sister
i think is mom dead yet
mom ma'am name i mean
careful with that you got it mean
please calm down tabby i know you're
hungry it's almost sandwich
time hang tight dear i'm making
sandwiches
oh all right maybe we can have frog legs
for dinner
all right okay i'll i'll leave you i'll
leave you alone
just gonna take the bowling ball
nice sandwich
what was that what just popped
did something just pop
oh right the bear trap
oh right
the bear trap right
oh why is this picture upside down
that's strange
hey okay
oh oh lucky
what in the hell wha what are you doing
you shadow monster what are you doing
you dancing on my corpse what kind of
douchebag move was that
okay but there was something there about
the ducky there was something about the
ducky there
there's definitely something going on
with that okay so this is just a horror
house where there's a million ways to
die
which is cool weirdly to say that is
interesting
i do like that about this game that is
fascinating i gotta give it that
what do i do with the ducky pro okay so
it's got to be something where i need to
throw
the ducky ew throw
no all right i will throw the ducky
throw ha there's a physics in this game
as a physics oh aren't you sweet
you want a ducky you want a ducky
what do i do with a goddamn ducky hey
what do i do with the duck
that's not yours is it must be the
previous homeowners
all right you have nothing else to say
about this i'll give it to my
sister hey sis
you still in bed fling all right
what the hell is that get it away from
me uh
no the duck what's wrong with the duck
you want duck
all right whatever find a loser i don't
like my duck
there's gotta be something to do with
the duck right oh
that's a new one you want duck
[Music]
all right no duck for you then oh
i hope that's the noise that i make when
i die just
just like a real goofy sound yeah i want
my death to be just
hilarious you know i don't need any
happiness
to my death my doom you know
all right so i've died in many ways in
many places here but uh
a few are still new
what happens if i just wait around long
enough and don't try to kill everybody
all the carpet i don't trust the carpet
carpet's no good
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh hi i have no interest in your
disgusting bath toy
will you hold me
[Music]
what about the bowling ball you like the
bowling ball
how about the bowling ball
you want the bowling ball we've been
here before haven't we will you hold me
no i'm good i'm i'm okay
oh good grandma grandma
grandma oh boy that can't be good
uh hello
oh no
you don't get away from me
that's not good um never had that happen
before to me
all right let me get my oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god my god oh my god
they're coming for me
oh my god they're all coming for me oh
my god
oh my god hold me hold me hold me hold
me oh my god
no mom no i oh
i'm dead two ways from i'm dead twice
well great all right can you hold
i want to hold you now could i hold you
that'd be appreciated
i'm just gonna go ahead and turn off all
the lights i don't know what did the
thing
but man that carpet really wanted me and
uh the shadow
everything just really was all about me
which i appreciate
very nice makes me feel wanted but also
uh go away
so like no matter what there's a timer
because
mom's gonna get you no matter what you
do
and that's like i don't think there's
any escaping that
aha take some of that cat
you want a bowling ball on your nog
oh no no no i didn't mean it oh god no
i'm horrible where am i
oh no pick up what did i get
what bucket
oh i didn't know i had a menu
i didn't know i had a minute oh
yeah that's my head
okay um hey
how are you doing there well this is uh
problematic hey kitty uh man this feels
wrong oh
i guess i just gotta get out of here
quick
quickity split huh
okay no
ye no not my head okay there is
definitely a way to get around there
with the axe my bear trap
bear bear trap bear trap for the right
put the rat in the trap and the rat's
gonna be in the trap you put a bear trap
on the ground
right is gonna wear a bear trap for a
hat
sorry i channeled a little inner ethan
there for a second
bam bam pic pick up
okay i got this i have
cycle unlock cycle cycle it's right
here you put it place it place it on the
ground yeah
get some mr bratman oh yeah come on
oh you're so stupid do i need to finish
you off
yes swing swing thank you
nice nice youtube
and maybe you as well just in case you
guys grow into something horrendous
okay nothing else here okay so i have
the axe
that's very good um
mama i'm doing this as a preventative
maybe that wasn't the best idea maybe i
didn't need to do that
maybe i didn't need to do that maybe i
didn't need to horribly murder my own
family
oh kitty
oh my god my oh but no i needed oh
no what have i done oh god
no hold me hold me doll
hold me i'm holding you i thought it'd
be my doom
help me oh no what have i done
what have i done what have i done
[Music]
i'm sorry what was happening in the
carpet
something was happening in the carpet
what was happening in the carpet
what is this game where are there so
many ways to die
what if i give the kitty milk would it
just give me the key
maybe there's a way to not kill anybody
because there's milk here right
milk
well god damn it you didn't want the
milk how about some of this
you got milk there oh
well that's not exactly where the
you know the but it's okay it's all
right
ah yeah
uh you know what i'll leave you be i'm
not gonna be very murderous here
something tells me i only have a limited
number of swangs
so let me go fix the bucket i'm gonna
try to save everybody maybe the lesson
oh god wait mom
uh mom watch out
uh look out hello
watch out i'm on a swing swung i'm not
swinging at you
just swing swanging
[Music]
oh i'm in hacker voice i'm in
hi what did i get oh
well ain't this delightful
oh okay so there's definitely something
down there
i just have to pull the carpet somehow i
don't know how
got to be something rubber duckies for
oh carpet oh
girls i made sandwiches okay coming mom
coming mom bringing my bowling ball
hello
hi mom thank you for the sandwiches
i'm gonna eat it oh
hey neighbor hi
oh hi again hello again honey seems
you're under the curse of this house
i've seen dozens of families move in
none of them were as cute as you though
you're a strong young girl i'm sure
you'll find a way out it's a shame about
your sister
she's been a bit depressed she needs her
big sister now more than ever
keep an eye on her make her feel safe
protect her
hop do it young lady uh-huh yeah
sandwich for
my sister oh
uh you want a sandwich
mom
guess you won't be eating with me so
rude oh okay
uh i'll take the
bucket i guess what was i supposed to
okay
put out the bush
[Music]
me ow i saved you i saved you
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
wait wait wait wait wait wait gun gun
gun bam
this game is hard so there is
definitely a way to save everybody i
just got to figure out what that is
was snail snail snail
snail snail hi oh a little girl and an
adorable one at that
my name is marty i'm a snail you smell
like you're having a hard time would you
like some help
oh thank thank you
thank thank you
uh so oh the snail lets me run more
oh
okay well that's
good i am much faster
okay okay i hate snails more than hey
father i'm gonna get you a sandwich
you're gonna get a sandwich before you
die
don't oh god mom hurry with those
sandwiches
no no no i could not do that that's
gonna kill you if he catches you with
that
uh wait uh uh sis sis wait sis
wait sis sis wait sis i'm gonna shoot it
before you get to it
it's oh no wait sis please um
[Music]
you just stay right there
turns out it's uh empathy okay
gonna get her a sandwich she's gonna be
fine
hey sis hey
you want sandwich there's nothing i hate
more than sandwiches
[Music]
let's preemptively sploosh this oh god
oh my god
jesus you can't do that to me
hey uh hey ma uh
oh the fat house feeds on your family's
pain daby
don't let it get the best of you only
you can stop this we're different from
the others we can remember
when it resets they forget use this to
your advantage great
hi mom tabby can you talk to snails tell
them i need more wine
howdy there partner your dad is coming
home soon okay good
well sister's dead and cat is not going
to light on fire though
you're still alive oh you're you're
still okay well i should have killed you
i guess
um
you don't do that to me hey my picture
has a snail on the head
that's nice that's real good um
no thank you no thank you oh my god
don't thank you no
no no no no no no no
no no oh god okay
[Music]
great man i'm i'm caffeinated by this
game
but it's clear that i'm missing some
steps i could definitely
figure out a way to stop the chandelier
from falling that that's like gotta be
my next step
right wait you never liked my music go
away tabby
we'll die together okay now it's not
falling
maybe it was just a time thing
maybe there's a way that oh what if i
destroy the
well that's not good i'll just wait here
until we die together
what is this by the way oh look at that
oh do i okay no never mind
well all right now i know how to get a
bullet
how about no how about definitely no how
about stay away from me
oh there's no way to get around that
there's no way even with the snail
there's no way okay so maybe there is
something to do with like the
shotgun and the blammo and the
chandelier there's got to be a way right
that seems like the solution
unless it's just the ax swing but i
don't think so
out out
it's like speedrunning tactics here hey
bud
starting to memorize this tune thank you
got that
get this okay is there not a way
and it doesn't look like it the angle is
not right can i just
there's got to be a way oh
i can break it
oh no god damn it okay
hi um you might notice it i sl i think
that
damn it i'm doomed i don't know how it's
doomed but it's doomed
oh oh
well that can't be good oh
i don't like daddy i don't like daddy
oh oh i i don't like daddy oh
god i don't like daddy oh oh oh
oh this is where i would use the gun if
i had a bullet bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang
[Music]
okay all right so there is definitely a
way
there's definitely a way to stop the
chandelier from falling
i just have to use my giganto brain
which is massive by the way it's really
big
what if i just don't let her get to the
piano what if i wait what if i sploosh
her with water
don't die yet hold on
what what
what oh i see you under there here just
kill me because i think i did something
wrong
okay so i don't know if the game pauses
entirely when you're talking
to someone but if i just talk to her
non-stop
you know what i mean so just hold right
there
we're talking yeah see the cat's
blinking so i'm assuming that means that
everything's still good maybe maybe
maybe no yes
let me see if like i can run quick here
and just pop my head in
okay uh sandwiches are
i'm just gonna hold here
and let me run back in real quick and
see if the progress is made ah damn it
okay
maybe i get oh my god oh my god no
no no no no god damn you
i guess i could have checked just if
time was passing in my menu
that probably would have been more
indicative okay it's
one oh it's 111 when i
uh damn it it doesn't okay so is there
something else to do
like can i splash her with water because
she doesn't seem to like that
okay the bucket's full let me get the
bucket hey
take some of this god damn it
i'm bucket filling crybaby not
funny look at what i'm doing
you see what i'm doing damn it oh
whoops
hey mom uh okay um
well this is not ideal um
huh okay look at this there's got to be
a way to open this
[Music]
oh well that was easy
okay i should have known that before hi
you're
probably fine hey what's going on there
okay do i do something about you
hello would you like a bucket i do
use arrow keys to aim
[Music]
oh i can shoot time
theory testing hey what's up sis uh
i mean that's bad but that's good it is
possible to save your sister and so long
as i can do that
i think i can end this episode with joy
in my heart
because i know that i did something to
save them so i'm going to do that
i'm going to do exactly that that's what
i'm going to do
snail's probably going to be mad at me
because another witness of murder
but whatever you know it is what it is
things happen hey you wanna think we
could take a break
yeah okay cool cool cool yeah let's take
a break bam
grab that grab that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah oh did i put the bucket down oh god
i did not put the bucket down oh my god
oh my god oh my god please tell me this
is going to save ma
please tell me i was in time
also what is the sound i'm hearing i'm
hearing like clickety clacks
a lot of clickety clacks going on not
sure what that's about
hey sis hey what's going on hey you see
this
oh man that sucks life is meaningless
well
this can't be happening no he's dead
this can't be happening no i have
nothing
i have nothing i need to go oh wait wait
wait wait wait wait oh oh my god oh my
god oh my god okay um
hey okay uh hold on hold on man don't
slip and die on that
oh boy well that didn't do anything
well that actively didn't oh oh wait
ma no okay ma you're good okay ah
hey uh okay uh oh geez hey sis
oh hold on this oh god i rans
hey is this oh god where's this oh god
oh i'm sorry you should watch out
there's kind of a monster in the there's
a monster in the turtle
[Music]
oh no
oh oh oh oh god well i mean uh
oh
okay all right i'm gonna leave that one
for there for now but this game is
fascinating
uh lots of stuff here happening here
it's a mystery there's just so much
going on
but it's good if you guys want more of
this let me know down in the comments
below because this
is very fascinating also what the hell
have you been doing with your life
why haven't you listened to distractible
yet why haven't you listened to bob's
fridge
episode of distractible it's freaking
hilarious
it's really good worth your time if ever
you listen to one
that's the one link is in the
description
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye